yeah okay we carry the Zipit empathy
I know patience is the key putting out
on my [ __ ] for free this is t we carry
beat Michael make the friend
good morning may 6th we are in the
building T with Gary Vee I am Gary Vee
big day thank you big day because twitch
has joined us live and so before we get
into the show big shout outs to a lot of
the twitch Zeus what's good Michele
Meyers on Facebook what's good
johnny-five what's good on twitch I love
that
so twitch families in the building
social cozy great to see you team with
Gary B is here thank you so much just
another a me really appreciate it really
really appreciate it
and thanks for everybody else who's on
every other platform big shout out to
everybody on Instagram we go a little
bootleg kind of gotta just film it like
this because it doesn't attach to the
incredible platform we use stream yard
which has been fantastic for us and has
really helped create this infrastructure
Dustin on the ones and twos good morning
to you brother how are you excellent
oh well yeah good accuracy to twitch for
some reason I don't know I'm not in the
comments I see it here within stream
yard but I'm trying to just watch it on
my phone like as if I was in a guess and
I don't know maybe I just don't know
what I'm doing yeah what's good Jason
from twitch hey hey what's up commish
how are you I'm well tell everybody who
you are this is awesome no it's not
awesome it's awesome to see you hi
everybody
Johanna Faris Commissioner of the Call
of Duty League and it's just an honor to
be here
good morning have you been everything
well everything's well you know what
we're busier now then we might have been
before this whole crisis hit you know so
for everybody's watching if you want to
where I'm the minority owner of the
Minnesota rocker which is a team in the
call of duty leak and it's been a great
venture so far and obviously with what
going on with kovat the macro eSports
landscape is getting more and more
attention and obviously we we have a
format where people do travel and and we
do have fans and we add the opening
weekend so we've we've been affected in
that way but the infrastructure work of
our game obviously scales to this new
world
what what's been the biggest
observations yeah I would say I use this
word a lot but the resiliency of the
business model right like we were
cranking on live events as you know we
launched a Minnesota you were there it
was fire especially for day one and you
know unfortunately this whole world is
going through unprecedented challenges
we all know that but we're still able to
operate thanks to technology and just
what do you sports affords you right so
I think there's just been a really cool
new wave of innovation that's frankly
has had to come through because of what
we're going through here and before we
get into your question how is it like
how has it been to be a commissioner of
a sport like it's kind of neat like fast
I know you want a good you know you know
I know we talked about this a lot as
being a part of sports of whether you
want to own a team or you know be on the
on the league off side but to be able to
to head this up is just an honor it's
incredible what's been the biggest
challenge and what's been kind of the
most pleasant surprise just out of my
own curiosity yeah I would definitely
say the biggest challenge is I think as
you know you know Call of Duty is a
monster franchise it's been around for
so long and the eastward has been along
around for a really long time right so
there was already these built-in
expectations built in ways of doing
things
rituals traditions the whole nine that
you really have to respect when you come
in this is not you know a brand new
never been done before
have a proposition for the league so we
were rebooting but we also had to marry
that with and you know honoring the
legacy of where we've been so I think
that's been an interesting challenge and
one that we've embraced you know biggest
surprises we've got everyone around the
horn yourself we've got some of the
biggest celebrities coming through the
doors we've got you know these Inc
credible competitors from you know the
scene both new names from pros who are
gonna you know make their mark going
forward pros you've been again in the
scene for many years so I would just say
it's just like the amount of faces in an
interest level in what we're doing from
people who've known about it for a long
time people were just getting involved
people coming in from traditional sports
it's really an interesting convergence
I'd say have a lot of different interest
industries I love it it's great to see
your face any questions before I move on
here no it's great to see you are you
well I am well you know just navigating
through this uh this you know the first
three four five weeks was really about a
makes your families okay you know just
like really quantifying the disease and
then and then very very quickly within
the first couple days of it just you
know there's seven companies under my
holding company you know that I'm a CEO
of I'm the CEO of the biggest company
within it so just navigating through
that world while also navigating through
just getting crushed in public speaking
like all that revenue is gone like you
know just you know wartime general [ __ ]
sure you know just just you know I think
a lot of people sign up for
entrepreneurship over the last decade
because it was cool and seemed easy and
fun and and the thing to do and I think
a lot of people are experienced
especially if you're under 32 and you
have a business your experience for the
first time you know a punch in the gut
and and really navigating it and it's
been a it's been a fun challenge yeah
well good luck with it thank you good
luck this weekend to the rocker we're
getting kids excited about it they're
gonna take care take care that was funny
was have one surprise Dustin I like you
guys you guys are up to all sorts of
tricks big shout out to everybody on
Twitch which is exploding here in the
comments section if you are interested
in being a mod we got a hit up Dustin or
somebody on the team
I don't just don't know if you want to
throw into the team Gary be chat maybe
Zane or Tyler Schmitt or somebody wants
to jump into the a lot of people you
know throwing their hands up to mop be
mods which can be fun I mean there's a
lot of incredible ecosystem that is
twitch I think has a lot of fun so we'll
see okay let's keep it moving
going on how you doing man I'm good
chess how are you are you sure yeah
thank you oh yeah it takes on yeah I
know
um yes oh good morning if anybody
doesn't know me my name is Chad Smith
I'm a content creator formerly on vine
on YouTube Instagram take time I've
never thought of you were in City but um
so my question for you is as a content
creator there can be a lot of just
emotional ups and downs and spent
especially for somebody like me I create
skits and content that's humorous and
supposed to bring people joy um so my
question is during times when I am NOT
authentically feeling joyful it's hard
to be motivated to create something
create content what advice would you
have for people to things like this yeah
that's a great question two things one
go to sleep like don't you know like you
know forcing it is you know this you've
probably had to persevere I've gone
through it on stage or in a live stream
like sometimes there's just something
else on your mind there's other things
going on and you can't be that hundred
you know so one for content creation I
think it's okay to not post for a day or
a week or even a month like as much as
I'm ambitious for my audience to be like
hey three four times a day
across all these platforms forty piece
of content a day that's when you're in
it if you're not in it then I think it's
super incredible to not do it or take a
break or have 36 hours pass and then get
on it or which I think would be really
powerful post a piece of content about
that so you're the funny guy and making
people laugh and escapism but then you
post like yo today's a tough day like
I'm not in character like yo this is
where I'm at I think that brings a lot
of value to people yeah yeah boner
ability is super powerful and honestly
it's something I struggle with and like
I in general don't like you know showing
vulnerability I don't like you know
talking about when I'm not in it I kind
of go in a cocoon like my whole career
my whole life really if I'm down in a
good place I'm just kind of
quote-unquote go to sleep because I'm
just not interests
in passing on my negativity or my
struggles on others however when you're
in the public domain there is a level of
like showing people like humanity and
things of that nature that could be
powerful that's highly personal but I
think one or two are really good options
as in that situation like don't beat
yourself up if you don't go at it for a
week just cuz you're a slump or feel the
power to actually just share like yo I'm
gonna sell it I'll be back just a couple
things I'm working through am I am I
dome you know yeah we're follow-up
question to that real-time okay yeah so
one thing I'm working on now also
especially while we have just it's time
to slow down while we're staying at home
is I'm working on building a greater
structure for I guess some of the
business and financial side of my stuff
but going back and forth between that
and creating can be difficult mentally
to like what do you do - I guess
separate the creative aspects of your
work from or to go back and forth
between the creative and business aspect
so if you work like I'm sure you hire
people and delegate tasks but for me
those two things come supernatural
because I can be creative and I am in
general business oriented but yeah I
think that's right I think you figure
out you know whether it's a manager or
something of that nature you know
somebody that you trust that can hold
down your the creative parts on you
unless you get a creative partner who
like writes or helps or you know things
of that nature but yeah yeah I think the
whole world is based on doubling down on
your strengths and and really sourcing
out your weaknesses I think that 98% of
the people that are watching right now
spend way more too much time trying to
fix their shortcomings when the reality
is the upside there is slightly you know
a slight growth whereas if they just
went ham on the [ __ ] that they loved and
their best that they get a ton more
value and then that actually extracts
dollars to be able to subsidize the
things that they are not as good at so
yes I do think hiring and building teams
is super powerful okay thank you and
appreciate that you I hope you do well
take a bite morning morning morning big
shout out to twitch
you guys are lighting up the comment
section oh gods ah what's up what's up
maybe Abel Franco a TAS in Jersey in the
building Abel you keep bringing up a
certain dailyvee episode and a timestamp
I need you to put that in the comments
of what that is or we might just need to
get Abel on the [ __ ] show dust let's
work on that
let's get Abel on the show all right
let's keep this going hey Jerry how are
you I'm well James how are you
best day of my life a challenge
five minutes with you thank you my
friend where are you from I from China
came here 10 years ago to do my breath
school and now I got my PhD everything
said I'm a data scientist but I feels
like I've already - my biggest thing
which has come to us and uh I was
wondering whoa what's the next how can
you come like garyvee and my version of
Gary you know that's my question
your that's a great question James the I
think the way to be your version of me
is to just truly be yourself and really
lean into what you want to be doing I
think so much of what I look back at at
the last 20 years professionally
specifically is you know me just being
comfortable being me you know when I
when I first wanted to do speaking
everyone told me that I couldn't curse I
kept cursing
when I started my career I worked for my
dad's liquor store even though you know
I knew there be you know certain parts
of that that like people would judge me
of like working in my dad's shop but you
know when I wanted to bet the farm
financially on investing in Facebook and
Twitter I you know I didn't listen to my
financial advisors that were advising
the wine store from a finance standpoint
I I I just felt very comfortable being
me and I think that's ultimately you
know the thing I'm best at is is
actually being me the thing I'm best at
is being Gary and I think free you know
not being your full self is is really
where most people get into unhappiness
when they're living for other people's
opinions and so I think you just you
need you know and that's really tough
Asian cultures and you know parents and
I i'm you know PhD like i get it i I
know that the kind of like symbols that
make it difficult but the way you can do
it is actual
just being your full self nice thank you
so much Gary oh and you know like if I
don't ask I'm just gonna regret my
wrestle no problem I don't want to leave
any regrets all I gotta come to work for
Gary the team guarantee I probably know
your answer already so so what do you
what do you what do you think you can
provide you know it's a very tricky time
more than ever in the last ten years we
have a fiscal responsibility that you
know in a world where we have to let
some people go to make our liquidation
challenges work it's hard to hire when
you're letting people go on the flip
side you know the reality is the answer
is maybe I think if you email me a serie
at vaynermedia and tell me what you can
do all happy I'll have Andy from my team
who runs my team and hires from my team
interview you no regrets here's your
chance
preciate you got love dusty love zing
like you guys agree
take care thank you let me give in the
comments here for a second man I'm
really loving the twitch action is on
fire like I'm loving it Facebook YouTube
Twitter you guys have to rev up your
comments here cuz twitch is out of
control right now yeah I was gonna say
it's like twice as much as normal
yeah because [ __ ] twitch knows how to
do it like that's that's the beauty of
twitch when you really look at it like
just the sheer energy of the community
reminds me so much of old-school like
chats and like and just like message
boards it's it's true internet culture
it's true community you know I think
YouTube has been pretty strong dust in
the comments yeah I think Facebook
should be up a little bit and and I
think that Twitter periscope is kind of
like low in comparison but twitch is
coming in here you know we might have to
get into like a whole like art like
battle between like all the streams and
see like which communities the most ham
so anyway let's keep it which is
exploding do you have any idea how many
people are on yeah it says on my thing
it's right on there 6000 for twitch okay
3,400 for Facebook yep
1600 on YouTube and about just under 300
on Twitter makes sense man twitch has
got the most already yeah like love it's
it's staying at 599 one so I have been
our twitch twitch fam
I haven't jammed enough on twitch to
know how to share it out but I would
love all of you to share this stream
right now to as many friends as possible
to create as much awareness for that
whether you use it within twitch or
whether you use it on Twitter to drive
here so alright let's keep it going
hun so you know what's good are you
doing very very good um yeah much love
from Germany man I appreciate you all
the positivity you and your team put out
it's really inspiring just appreciate it
thank you so much so my question is
maybe to give you first a little bit of
background over the last three years I
did basically I alert my skills I got
some degrees because I wanted to work
for a big brand and after that I got an
internship with one of the biggest
brands in the world and I got the
opportunity to work for them which was
amazing and I basically said well I want
to break the door in right after putting
through the door now so when I go in and
I worked my ass off to get there and
there were a lot of opportunities
opening up to the end of my internship
but right around that time
Korona broke loose so the opportunities
vanish and now I'm living in my parents
basement
basically again with 24 which is fine so
I said let me lean into my personal
brand because I'm like I'm into fitness
I've been training for like eight years
little bit over there and I'm also a
coach so I said well I'm gonna develop
my brand a little bit and push that on
Instagram and wherever because I'm just
in it but I catch myself looking back
because I don't want to miss out on the
corporate world as well because I love
that as well I met so many amazing
people so it's like you know can I
combine that easily like you know as
soon as we get to some sort of normalcy
and corporations are hiring again which
they will you can apply for a job or
another internship and be right back
they're like
this is this is a moment in time and the
beauty for you is you're so young you
have your entire life in front of you
and then if you want to do the fitness
stuff in your personal brand you can do
that after hours and on weekends and
then your and and the other thing is you
may change your mind in three years or
six years you know that's true that the
biggest issue that I see out there is
that we don't put changing your mind on
a pedestal
I believe that changing my mind is my
greatest strength as an operator the
ability to change your mind
is powerful most people fear changing
their mind because they're worried about
what people will judge them for when
just a year ago they said I'm gonna be a
fitness coach and then nine months later
they're selling pizzas and everyone's
like oh you're full of [ __ ] and and it's
not about being full of [ __ ] it's you
[ __ ] changed your mind yeah that's
true
I think laziness and changing your mind
are two things that are completely
misunderstood I think most people think
that changing your mind is a show of
weakness and you don't know what you're
doing I think it's the reverse people
obviously very much look down on
laziness believe it or not for somebody
who's like hard work hard work I
I actually see laziness as an insight to
that you're not passionate about that
thing and you just need to do another
thing yeah helps so much maybe don't
maybe what what I'm saying is I
apologize what I'm saying there is you
can do the corporate thing and then four
years later be like wait a minute
actually I loved being a health you know
professional and then you can do that
and you'll still [ __ ] be under 30
yeah yeah true yeah I don't know I just
feel stuck right now because it was
always going so fast and I was ready to
kill it you know because I'm robots like
go there there was people that were
ready to have the greatest life of all
time that got hit by a car and died
there are people who just built a
monster business in the 1940s in Europe
and then a war broke out there are
people like there are people who were
ready to kill it and actually died from
COBIT yeah it's like I'm at the [ __ ] are
you complaining about
no like no I'm you know what yeah it's
like don't be sad
be happy yeah look anybody who's
watching right now if you did not have a
loved one died from Corona you need to
be happy I don't give a [ __ ] about your
job I don't give a [ __ ] about you know
the miss thing I don't give a [ __ ] about
that you missed your favorite concert or
you're sporting a bit like like we need
to put [ __ ] in perspective
yeah true so you're winning
the fact that you about a parents home
to go to is is better than a lot of
people yeah thanks you just need to
switch it it's kind of like an on/off
switch instead of spending your time
thinking about like oh god I'm so
unlucky just when I was finally there
I'm out of a hundred years this pandemic
my friend do you understand that if this
pandemic started three months earlier
Kobe Bryant would be alive shame you
know what I mean
if this pandemic started happening a
year ago at the same time my great
friend and the great unbelievable young
artist Nipsey Hussle would be alive like
like bro don't be sad like like honestly
I'm kind of happy I'm glad that you got
punched in the stomach
because it's gonna make you more
resilient in the future it's gonna make
you more thoughtful when you make
decisions in the future because you've
now lived through [ __ ] can happen yeah
yeah so true you know just to just
change your mind keep it up yeah just
like um not only keep it up realize this
is an opportunity yeah yeah man I'm
trying to learn everyday bro like I'm
trying to make it work I'm just trying
to be the best self every day and just
but I get what you mean yeah baby good
maybe one more thing that maybe relates
to it a little when I was working there
like there were a lot of positive people
and I drew energy from them I love to
work surrounded by positive people
because I'm positive as well it's just a
certain time but now that I'm back here
I'm missing like the influence influence
of positive P so put positivity in your
ear
I do man that's why I'm talking to you I
appreciate it bro so more so more why
don't you why don't you contact
everybody in your phone and send them a
google hangout link and get on you know
what every day at six o'clock for two
hours and just shoot positivity take the
initiative [ __ ] dwelling [ __ ] go all
in you take control you take control you
create positivity why don't you text all
the [ __ ] people that you found
positive and say hey man hey hey gal do
you want to go on zoom' tonight let's
get 20 of our friends together think of
it I literally go through your phone
from a to [ __ ] Z and find every
positive person you know and send them a
link and say I'll see you at 8 p.m.
tonight
yeah man that's that's a great idea
well good that's what I'm here for thank
you so much take care
stay well you too listen just like I
told me know like you're in control like
like you want positive people go gather
them you throw the party you liked some
party that doesn't exist anymore great
go and [ __ ] throw your own party one
[ __ ] control out here your [ __ ]
control out here
let's go [ __ ] 7000 people on Twitch
let's give this to 10k Twitch fam hit up
everybody that you know that [ __ ] with
twitch I'll get my [ __ ] together and
really understand how the platform works
so I don't know how you can message us
or share this orco screen it or the [ __ ]
you guys do because you're the [ __ ]
best go do it
hey guy how are you my friend what's
your name I'm good I'm sorry and I'm
from Asia
sir Lanka I can't yes
okay so I just get right into it so I
started like creating content in 2013 so
and like since then I've been making
content like I'm all good with that like
I've been following my passion and I've
been making videos and I've been like
like I'm all good in that side like you
understand what I mean yes I do so the
thing is yeah so the thing is I I am
struggling to post it like I don't know
oh wait a minute so you can make the
content but you don't put it out yeah I
don't I don't like I'm a caring for
others like okay so always mean like
this like it's always it
it's always like like like telling
someone else's story is easy for me but
telling my own story to the world is
hard
do you want to tell your story or do you
enjoy telling other people's stories
because there's an incredible amount of
storytellers who are far better about
telling their story then then are people
that are good at telling their story
yeah I just wanted to try but I'm like
are you scared by the fear are you
scared of what your parents or relatives
will think are you scared of what
strangers will think you know coz what
you're worried about is judgement yeah I
think so I just wanted to hear that from
you like I'm here to listen but yeah I
know that you know the answer which is
why I want to go a little bit deeper
which is are you there do you think
you're more worried about your parents
or relatives opinion or do you think
that you're more worried about anonymous
people's opinions what would you say
when I ask you that I know anyone say
but like my family supports me like do
it everything I know that's awesome yeah
you know did you do you know how to ride
a bike
yeah do you know how to swim no okay are
you scared of swimming yes yeah I was -
as a kid art were you scared to ride a
bike at first yeah goes you putting out
content is similar to swimming and
riding a bike with swimming you you
still haven't done it with riding a bike
you were scared to get hurt and fall off
but eventually you figured it out you've
had two experiences that are cliche -
almost every child of like two things
that one could fear and you figured one
out and you haven't figured out another
one that's who you are with content you
need to become the siren that learned
how to write the bike not the one that
has stayed away from swimming you
understand yeah like I had a super I
call it my supervisor because like if
put some content out like it grows up
like my first tiptoe period were like
4,000 views and same when you do it
blows up so you're a great content
creator yeah I know it like I'm scared
of posting so thank for that rice and
one last thing before I go please can
you please follow me on Instagram like
it will really boost my confidence to
like for some real [ __ ] you got it
what's your handle I see it here mm-hmm
I got you my friend so let me ask you a
question you have a lot of followers for
only five posts do you take down posts a
lot I mean like I create content for
others like for businesses and they tag
you
yeah did you know I don't do it money
you made this no no I didn't make it I
wonder like no no worries yeah don't get
I love a brother good luck
thank you very much okay let's keep it
going like it answered it's good right
appreciative polina big shout out to the
YouTube crew Rhys cream restream
restream I see everybody going hard on
that Polina why what's good Daniel made
sanben what's good
yes that was a pitch Sam bet he he
completely came just for the follow
which [ __ ] it I respect the hustle let's
keep it going
Ashley how are you how's it going good
how are you
awesome well first and foremost I hope
you and your family are safe I'm doing
well we are thank you f awesome so two
questions first question is that I've
been doing I went to school for
advertising I got my business degree and
I just I've always loved marketing
branding advertising I moved to New York
three years ago
and it's interesting because I consider
myself to be really
and I work really hard and I love it
like I love a company like vaynermedia
especially van or sports because I'm a
sports fanatic so you know the two
worlds colliding and for the fast past
three years I've had jobs but I've never
been able to get far enough in an
interview process or really be able to
get a job or come close to a job that
I'm really passionate about and I find
it interesting because I work hard and I
love it and so I'm just wondering where
do you think like the disconnect lies
between my capabilities and actually
kind of getting my foot in the door with
it you're accepting jobs I'm accepting
jobs you're accepting jobs okay
disconnect as you've said yes to people
that have offered you jobs that weren't
as ideal as they could have been because
you didn't go hard enough to get as many
interviews in the five to 40 places that
could be the place the disconnect is
you've said yes oh god how ironic okay
and so I just okay all right yeah I mean
yeah I know a mind-blower or not
it is mind-blowing it's like so fun for
me you know it's like there's so many
things I'm not good at but like
navigating life decisions and like [ __ ]
like this it there's just so much
clarity for me like you're talking I'm
listening enjoying the your vibe and
then and then it's just you know the
answer is you shouldn't have said yes to
the jobs you've said yes to and you
should have kept going to get interviews
in the places you want you like you
should have spammed vaynermedia's
thousand employees in perpetuity until
one of them got you like got it you
haven't gone hard enough in the
conviction of getting the jobs in the
places that you wanted to and then what
put the nail in the coffin was you said
yes to the jobs that you've said yes to
okay well with that in mind I decided to
go straight to the source which is you
and so if you ever find the opportunity
for Vayner sports you let me know
because Sports and marketing is my jam I
love all my jam well who do you like I
can't tell
you're not gonna hire me I'm a doctor
I'm a Dolphins fan I'm from Miami I'm
sorry I know well could I live in LA do
you live in Miami I live in New York I
live in New York I'm here because of her
you know would you marry me
would you move to Miami and work for the
Dolphins 100% why don't you send me an
email right now to Gary at vaynermedia
and put in Miami Dolphins I'm sure you
know that I'm business partners with
Steve Ross the owner to dolphins and I
have real connections or maybe you don't
know that I didn't know that because I
would have most definitely led with that
but you taught me anyway which is which
is awesome I loved you Gary at
vaynermedia I want a job with the
Dolphins let me see what I can do
Gary you're your hero I appreciate it
and I just want to say you know I think
it's really inspiring that what you've
done is you know obviously you can't go
to Hudson Yards you can't do what you do
you can't travel but you're still you
know you're helping people everywhere
and I think it's awesome and it inspires
me thank you wait till this next part of
our chapter I'm gonna really help you
send me that email Gary you're the best
have a great day bye ah sh t answer the
questions in the comment section the
person that's laughing in the background
is my mom who never wants appear in any
of my content but she's literally
watching right there and she's laughing
her ass off thank you
all right let's keep it going no Gary
John good hey thanks for having me on
been following you for a while but I'm
in hospice sales so if anyone doesn't
know Hospice is end-of-life here so we
go to we go to nursing homes mainly our
main remaining referral source nursing
homes have been hit the hardest out of
all this you know so we're not able to
go in our partners aren't able to go in
there so I started a health care
professional group on Facebook actually
back in December but it really took off
in March with everything going on so I'm
just trying to keep everyone connected
helping people share their skills I've
been doing one-on-one interviews with
different people you know in the
long-term care field trying to provide
as much value as possible but I don't
know how to expand on it I don't know
what is what does expand on it mean to
you
I don't know where I want to go with it
like it's doing well you know I'm
getting everyone connected like last
night we had a Cinco DeMayo event we had
new facilities showing off their
facilities so you can't do tours you
know so they're able to show them off so
you're trying to figure out if this
should be an evergreen kind of nonprofit
brand builder or should you convert it
into a business right yeah like so the
people that I'm working with are direct
referral sources so they'll refer
patients to me but they're good good
people to have on your side you know
indirect referral sources I like
networking people together I've liked
doing the interviews with people I don't
know if it's some sort of side gig that
I could put together well let me let me
throw something at you when I when I
started making Gary Vee videos that
weren't wine videos there you know there
was there was no obvious path to what I
was gonna do with it I just knew that
building brand and sharing my thoughts
and being a good person would lead to
opportunity so just keep going with it
and see where where it ends up it's and
it's similar to the young lady that we
just had you know it's not only going
with it like doing the right things
always the right thing like building
brand is always the right thing like
karma is the most practical strategy and
business like kindness caring like like
people are so confused right now cuz
there's so much political tension
there's so much anger there's so much
stuff going on in our world precoded
that people are super confused like the
way you actually win is by doing all the
nicest [ __ ] humanly possible like like
like nice guys win like this whole like
nice guys you know finished last makes
me laugh
nice guys may lose that race that you're
talking about the micro but they're
winning in life dick faces may win that
race but they're losing in life and so
doing all this stuff but also similar to
the last call not saying yes right away
if it's not the right thing there's been
a million opportunities for me to
monetize things that I've said no to
that later
I monetized and monetized far more
successfully so it's not only stay the
course John it's when the first
opportunity comes to sell it to get a
sponsor to create a referral program it
might not be the right one and having
the strength and the foresight and the
strategy capabilities to realize it's
not the
time to monetize or to act on this is a
huge deal right now I appreciate that
because actually I was putting out like
LinkedIn content to when I started
getting people offering me different
jobs and I like what I'm doing now so I
didn't want to jump on anything anything
new just a joke and another question
though I've been trying to put out
LinkedIn content hospice education
videos you know just are really cool but
how do you how do you do such a serious
topic can you can you do that on my
anything like that I don't know if you
know listen the answer is you can do
anything on anything like Hospice is
like you know very heavy [ __ ] right and
so I you know yeah you know you could
but I would probably say that LinkedIn
and a Facebook group are probably like
the smarter places to go with that I
think Facebook's super important
Facebook inherently is old they're you
know you've got a lot of you've got a
lot of 50 60 year olds on Facebook who
are facing the extremely sad moments of
their parents being in a place where
they're starting to get ill or
terminally ill or things that nature so
you know it's a tough subject matter to
talk about you know I'm sure I'm sure
John when you're like living through
life and like going to like the you know
the neighborhood picnic and it's like
hey I'm John hey I'm Rick no what do you
do I'm like I'm sure you know I'm sure
like people don't want it you know what
like the reverse for me it's been like
malign and social medium people always
want to lean in you know I'm sure you
just in living in real life you know
that it's a subject matter that's kind
of tough for people I do think LinkedIn
and Facebook especially I think is a
very powerful platform for you janna I
think base looks great actually because
I've been trying to get more into like
the like the senior care groups for for
the adult children so I can even if
they're not going to be referred to us
because you know we're only in like the
Philadelphia area so if there's
somewhere that's your way at least I'm
giving them information help them make a
decision so I I think keep going and the
opportunity will absolutely show itself
and then be thoughtful when when the
time is there and and better-half 206 is
right right hospice is about loving
caring it is like the kindest most noble
thing it's just an uncomfortable subject
matter
for so many people because it's like a
death sentence in a lot of people's
minds but I couldn't agree more with
better half 2 or 6 the humanity and just
thank you for the industry you're in
brother oh yeah no problem thank you
Gary all right okay thank you bye bye
Dustin yo somebody wrote that I was a
goober I thought I thought that would
have been a good one to flash up I
wasn't sure if it was the right time for
that why loving care
ya know somebody razzing on me is always
okay there's never a wrong time to throw
up a negative comment alright cuz
because I [ __ ] absorb that [ __ ] like
a [ __ ] monster there's another guru
for you
alright let's keep going extreme Zak
how's it gone things are well you I'm
doing great okay I'll I'll dive right
into it because I kind of have two
questions if you have time but so as
someone who has become a self-proclaimed
expert at right hook marketing for my
furniture store I'm wondering what type
of content can we make for people that
would be more of a job content in the
context of a furniture store that's not
very design oriented we're more
entry-level to mid-level so that people
aren't necessarily so obsessed with the
furniture itself or the real designing
aspect um by still talking about the
utility of it like a $80 chair or $13
chair or whatever the [ __ ] we're talking
about here still has information about
it that people might care about right
like I don't know like what's the
cushion feel like like what woods it
made of like where is it made of from
like like you know for everybody's
watching that doesn't know the
terminology we're using Zach's being
very kind he's referencing to a book
that I wrote years ago called Jab Jab
Jab right hook and the concept is most
people [ __ ] up social media and like for
that matter because they just go into
right hooks which is they're trying to
land the sail and Zak clearly and this
works on digital marketing has figured
out sales content right here's a cup
$6.99 you know away we go
and so that's a right hook going in for
the sail I've noticed and
have been proven over the last 10 years
that people that are best at marketing
know how to throw out value jabs that
also that helps them close their sales
and so what he's asking is you know you
know how do we how do we find a balance
in a retail environment where we're
selling [ __ ] second and I get where
you're going right like there's
obviously the super high-end things
where the design the designer herself or
himself the fabric type I still think
you talked about you know utility and
practicality at that price point right
yeah I thought about doing things like
you know review right there stop right
there no the whole games breaking cuz
you said I thought right right like this
is you know you [ __ ] me and T you
don't you know where I'm going you don't
need like I [ __ ] hate I thought
because every I thought is is a missed
opportunity from you putting out
something that was absolutely yeah and
okay again if you've got time here I've
got another follow-up question here so
I've just recently started to like my
own advertising agency basically what
I'm doing for furniture extreme which is
the company that I work for people help
other furniture stores do the same thing
with their marketing so my question is
you always talk about trying to Pat
culture and scale the unscalable what
has we've noticed with our marketing a
thing that always indexes the best is
human interaction right then when you
can put that at at scale like you talked
about all the time but a question is can
i scale myself or other furniture stores
like would you for instance run ads for
a different wine company like as gary i
just getting that for Gary B or is that
something that you would kind of leave
off to the slide kind of torn on that I
guess one more time do you own this
furniture store no I don't want it like
I'm basically like just like a number
two in command like I'm a I'm just an
employee I'm an employee absolutely so
for me it's different because with Wine
Library it's my family business and with
empathy it's my business and you know
I'm not an employee so of course I would
not do that for another wine store okay
but if I was you I would go start my own
company right yeah which is what which
is what I've done here I mean the
interesting part is my my mentor one of
my mentors I should say and the owner of
the business is also partnered with me
and the
got it so the owner of this business and
your mentor who you have a great
relationship with recognize that you're
talented and instead of like trying to
suppress you and not do your own thing
came in and as a partner in this
business
oh yeah no he's the he would never
suppress me like that's awesome
Tim's watching right now and Jim I have
some of him Tim I have so much respect
for you
Tim Tim is doing something that I have
the most admiration for right which is
super hard sometimes they catch a young
talent by the tiger by the tail they
know they've got something good it's
helping their business that person
doesn't own the business sure they can
pay them more but a lot of times when
that kid realizes wait a minute I want
to do something for myself and they go
that owner resents it or tries to
suppress it or tries to not make it
happen instead of leaning in the biggest
thing I've learned in my life is you
can't stop winners right that's a great
job by Tim big shout out to Tim on that
silver what so what's the question on
that well my question is again like
should I can I or should I I know I get
annoyed sort of can but I can scale
myself within furniture extreme and like
be like me sitting on the couch and
stuff like that works really well I mean
talking about this come on in all that
sort of stuff but if I'm running ads for
another store I think no I think you
need to build them up okay but I'm like
do it for instance like like like
there's a like a different store in
Edmonton for instance like could I kind
of almost like white-label myself and be
like I'm just I'm Zack not extreme Zack
but i'm zack you yes yes as long as
Tim's cool with it right which yeah
that's true I never knew he wasn't stuff
I mean I believe that I can tell so the
answer is yes when you when and if you
guys have that conversation right okay
so it's it's something you think and if
you can if you get good at building up
other people notice what I do with my
content I made you know Chris Motte and
Eric assed nurse stars on Wine Library
TV I made India and stunwin and right
look what's going on with Dustin look at
his face Dustin show your [ __ ] face
look look yes it's never been so popular
is [ __ ] life he doesn't know what to
do with his newfound failure Dustin
you're totally confused right tell
everybody you're [ __ ] confused very
confused yeah so Zach you know like what
I do is I use my platform and a cosign
people and what's happening Dustin's
getting bombarded with [ __ ] 400
people like you be my podcast guy like
like you don't like d-roc and Dustin
have opposition like Dean Rock has
unlimited options do you raka make 10
times more money by leaving me but he
realizes for himself that hey he likes
me I assume the rock I love you and like
be like he can go on you know and and
win with me longer because he feels
that's the way what you can do is you
can go into those other stores and sit
on the couch with the owner of that
store and create that cosign exactly so
I guess my question is is like so I can
do that but my problem I'm running into
is like for instance even in this other
store that's only like a three-hour
drive for me it's like I'm so busy like
in a furniture extreme like working on
that like to even drive the three hours
I can do that you know a couple times a
month or sort of thing but I can't scale
that if I was to get a client in my
hometown of in California for instance
so is that I don't want to lean into
something that I can't scale I guess but
I'm always trying to scale the things
that are unscalable like you talk about
the whales so yeah I I scale unscalable
things and I built a thousand person
infrastructure and it's by the way that
thousand percent of the structure
started with one person right so
basically just do what you can with that
side but then just like and then and
don't just be nice to furniture right
well how do you mean I guess elaborate
on that story thethe storytelling for if
you're an agency you know the tactics
you may not be the expert for the
subject matter but you'd surely know how
to based on running ads and creating
content you know what's working on
social networks so you can deploy that
without being the face of the flower
shop or the baker I'm gonna [ __ ] real
estate I can that's like that's what I
was kind of thinking originally with
doing it but then I was like you know
some of the things that work the best is
literally like you're gonna you know a
selfie video where I'm just sitting on a
couch and I'm talking I'm like this is
the best ad we've ever run or one of
them and I'm like you know but then you
can direct somebody else to do it right
kind of give them the instructions you
don't need to be the face listen Zach I
know you've got a great [ __ ] face but
you don't need to be in every [ __ ]
piece of content you can tell Karen to
be in her content and Karen may suck as
the flower shop person and then you have
to go another route or Karen might be
more charismatic and it will work like
that Russian Sephora lady yesterday you
know she's gonna win yeah yeah no that's
I guess yeah I guess I have a hard time
sometimes just that like you're saying
like certain people are better on camera
than people are
it just seems like in the furniture
industry that's kind of a hard thing to
find other people who are sort of like
that but I promise you Zach you're not
the only talented person in the
furniture industry I'm sure you're first
but so that's what I mean like it's like
I get it theoretically but you've got a
deal in reality like I'm sure you know I
get it right now that makes sense man
I'm I'm coming to see you an amateur in
Rico but we were supposed to do now and
I know it's been rebooked and I hope it
sticks I mean everything's so on but I
will get my ass to Edmonton I'm [ __ ]
obsessed with it I'm bringing my I'm
bringing my Gary B sneakers my boss has
four pairs he knows they're gonna be
worth someday a whole bunch when you buy
the gym watching this buy those shoes
because if you buys the Jets those are
gonna be worth millions yeah see you
Gary take about millions but I
definitely expect Gary B's to be
flipping in 25 years for at least a
thousand and I think there about a
hundred on ebay now so free bunny if
you're willing to wait 25 years all
right let's keep going James looks good
I'm good how are you grand rising it's
really good to see bro haha it's good to
see you first I wanna thank you for this
opportunity you know [ __ ] is priceless
and those sneakers is gonna be priceless
I've been watching your videos for a
minute and today I'm looking for tactics
you know there was a lot of [ __ ] I want
to do you know I know what I want to do
I saw an old dailyvee where this lady
asked how she could manage multiple
projects and you know she wasn't worried
about spreading too thin it was
confusion for her for me it's dividing
my time you know not splitting my focus
put them all in the each project okay so
I was just wondering how could I divide
my time by dividing it okay fair enough
very fair and then play with me here to
play with me here okay
like what's the shrug 'el the struggle
is like I just got too much [ __ ] going
on and like I just can't like focus on
one thing at a time and then move to the
next thing you know what I mean like
they're the very different like what are
things creative and then one things like
more finance you know
okay so what's what do you do you I
think I think you can switch to them I
just think that you might have you might
just be beating yourself up
and
decided that because you have two things
that when you that you're not
accomplishing either because you're
stretched too thin
like what like what's like what's making
you think you can't balance it probably
myself you know yeah that's exactly
right like if you told me like they all
failed that's the results but like I
think I think a lot of people just
create an ideology or like one person
they respect or like or they think his
successful tells them that they need to
focus on one thing and then just believe
them hmm like why can't you balance
create the creative thing you're doing
and the finance thing you're doing hmm I
I would argue you are balancing them as
long as one of them doesn't go out of
business or as long as one doesn't bring
you deep unhappiness you actually are
balancing them I think I think people
just get into philosophy for no [ __ ]
reason not for real I appreciate that
and yeah just one more question when I
don't have an audience to ask how do I
figure out the best way to provide value
and engage them you know like I don't
give a [ __ ] about the followers the
likes like I want 17 real followers that
comment on every post I'm making by
making making by making because you
gonna have one piece of content have you
started tick tock
nah ha ha this for me tick tock is free
audience probably is listening and by
the way I see you twitch you're almost
at 10,000 people I [ __ ] with you guys on
Twitch you guys are really going out of
heart uh
tick tock is free audience bro mm-hmm
like how many you like you know you know
that I was gonna ask you that question
how the [ __ ] did you come on here this
morning and not set up a tick tock
account before we got on here it's free
audience you're right I know I'm right
it's free [ __ ] audience you want 17
real fans make one tick tock when we
hang up right now and you got it your
big [ __ ] dream of seventeen James I
just gave it to you hang the [ __ ] up
make make a tick tock of you brushing
your [ __ ] teeth and you've got 17
free fans all right all right hey one
one last request you know bunny win
Edmonson cannot link you up okay let's
go damn everyone [ __ ] Edmonton all
right now I'm down south I get east
peace all right let's keep it going
enough like hey hi hi I'm here how's it
going good what's your name my name's
Tori Tori it's so nice to meet you nice
to meet you too um so I'm a photographer
and videographer and based in Central
Florida
I am I focus mainly on weddings and
portraits things like that I studied art
and photography all through college and
I worked really hard to like keep myself
at a debt I worked like multiple jobs
I've done everything I can to you know I
I went to college knowing I wanted to
own my own business I didn't you know do
it because anyone told me to it's like I
viewed it as my fitness investment and
so I've carried that mentality of like
being financially you know safe with my
money like into my business and I feel
like it might be holding me back you're
not investing enough what's that you're
not investing enough cuz you're very
conservative with the dollars right so
like things like wedding wire than not
you know going to like wedding Expos
things like that like try it it's let me
give an example I ran for wine text ooh
good segue get in here
Dustin for wine text right I ran an ad
in a three hundred thousand person email
newsletter from one of the biggest wine
kind of companies this week two days ago
right I couldn't wake I couldn't wait
like it was like Christmas like I
couldn't wait to you know see how it was
gonna do but I also knew and I even told
my fam I was like I even told a story
about like one of my worst you know
advertising moments when I bought a huge
ad on luxury comm in 1997 for Wine
Library and I thought I was gonna change
our company we got like two orders and I
spent like ten thousand dollars which
was like a billion dollars for that
small business at the time and punchline
is on Monday it didn't do well like it
just didn't do well right and and I was
thrilled because I got the learning and
I could afford it it was a lot of money
but I could afford it my dad's company
could afford it that was that why the
decision was made you have to not fear
being wrong and you have to not value
the cat cash is king
but when it holds you back
I loved I think you're being very
self-aware I think you can feel it so
what I would say is this everything you
just brought up the not expose things
that nature you have to do them when you
can afford it to go to zero like Tori
you basically have to you know how you
paid for school and [ __ ] work your
[ __ ] face off you you need to realize
the education of doing a an expo the
education of doing the not the X the
execution of doing the wire the
execution of paying a wedding influence
or a fortune right you need to realize
that you doing that is you paying for an
education but better than [ __ ]
college you might actually be right half
the time and it pays it back immediately
you need to convert it not into I made a
bad business decision I lost the money
you need to convert it into I'm gonna
learn from this and if it goes to zero
it's just gonna be a funny [ __ ] story
I tell one day just like Gary did about
luxury calm right if I ever find you
[ __ ] luxury calm [ __ ] that rip me
up on a punch in neck anyway Tori that's
the game right if you can go to 0
every decision has to be I'm gonna spend
8000 on this and if it goes to 0 I won't
die right you got it yeah
is that how you think about it um yeah
because right now I'm I'm only three
years into like really trying to get my
business started up and I I'm working a
part-time job still I work at a
photography museum and it's it it takes
up a lot of my time so being able to
work from home is kind of like been like
a nice taste of like what I'm hoping to
get to where I can work my business
full-time so that's where I'm at is like
I'm I'm still not financially you know
able to do my photography full-time I
have to work I do my guns I've great
news yes I mean I know but I don't know
see the funniest part of that sentence
is you can't put the butt in there take
the butt out go back to the part of I
know right
how old are you I'll be 30 in January
I worked in a liquor store when I was
dirty yeah I know I'm impatient I know
that at 30 I worked in a liquor store
and when it was the holidays I would
literally ring up people I was a cashier
I would literally stock shelves I would
literally pack boxes and have them ship
out mm-hmm that's what I was doing yeah
and I'm not I'm not afraid of the hard
work I'm not really
I needed [ __ ] but you're impatient for
the thing you love yeah can I look your
day job is is are you maximizing dollars
there are you learning something there
like is it just a job it's just a it's
right now it's been great because it is
within my field of interest it's a time
okay photography but that's cool it's a
desk job and it's not it's a paycheck I
think for a lot of people like you you
need to get more more strategic about
the paycheck like what I would be doing
probably at all times is applying for
other jobs that either give me more
dollars so I can invest so I can leave
or something that may lead to more
opportunities where I enjoy even more
being the right hand of somebody who I
admire 10 times over as a much better
photographer I think where you're miss
playing it and I see a lot of people
commenting about this so it's resonating
is the strategy of just the paycheck
needs to be smarter and for a lot of
people here they need to work at
7-eleven so they can be on their phone
the whole time building up their
personal brand and make less money than
they are at a job that pays them two
times more but they have no time during
the eight hour day because they actually
have to do their job so they have to
take even a shittier job but that's a
strategy you might need to take a job
that pays you even more that you might
even like less because like you said
it's a desk job anyway so yeah the
facade is it's in your fields but it's
not in your [ __ ] field so why not
make eight thousand more a year by
taking some other job because that
strategy gives you that eight thousand
you know six thousand post-tax to put
into the knot or do a thing that could
change your game or take less than the
desk job but then become the apprentice
or right hand or gofer of
greatest photographer that you've ever
you know witnessed hmm you have to get
much more strategic about your day job
right okay and I guess that's kind of
where I'm at - I've been in Daytona and
it's about an hour out from Orlando
which is where most of my clients for my
photography come from and I've been
meaning to get back to Orlando because
that's where I'm originally from but my
job is keeping me in Daytona I want to
punch your job in the [ __ ] face I'm
gonna [ __ ] go down to Daytona
don't stress brake of course and then
quickly we'll go over and punch your job
in its face your [ __ ] job is pissing
me off Tour mean to you sometimes don't
you need to apply to 800 [ __ ] I don't
give getting a [ __ ] Pluto content
costume and work and [ __ ] Disney I
don't give a [ __ ] at the [ __ ] Orlando
ok
okay I'm being serious get your ass to
[ __ ] in Orlando okay
what are we doing here the job has no
[ __ ] value you're just being in
you're just in a [ __ ] hamster wheel
right get the [ __ ] out of that job now
of course this happens when 50 million
[ __ ] people lose their jobs so it's
not like you know like the timing is
[ __ ] wack however that doesn't stop
you applying to 800 jobs mm-hmm like the
[ __ ] are we doing here like I think I'm
scared too I think I've always because
I'm always so like what's the next goal
what's the next goal what's in a soul
I'm scared to take the step backwards to
take a job that like [ __ ] we've been
doing here for [ __ ] a month on tea
with charity humility is the [ __ ]
superpower humility is the unlock mm-hmm
you need to be humble right like I want
it like Tory needs to be humble like I
need to go to a Knicks magic game when
they get back to playing go to the
stadium sit there and see you serving
some [ __ ] popcorn and then I'm gonna
say that [ __ ] girls on her way right
humility get your [ __ ] ass to Orlando
people going crazy about your photos
let's put up your Instagram again thanks
like people are going nuts like hey
anybody like if you
getting married hire me listen to me get
to [ __ ] Orlando and that means
applying to 500 jobs this week and
that's what you do for three hours at
night for real and by the way there are
a lot of business that are exploding
during this time there's a lot that are
struggling going out of business on the
flip side there's a lot that are growing
yeah I've been getting lots of inquiries
lately so I've not been feeling any sort
of you know heat from this it's actually
been kind of nice stories there anything
keeping you in Daytona that I don't know
about just the job just a constant
paycheck mm-hmm that's what I Blaz my
face off that people in this generation
don't use the internet at night to get
them out of their [ __ ] jail you need
to be [ __ ] applying for jobs 24/7 two
hours a [ __ ] night in [ __ ] Orlando
marine okay two hours a night tour two
hours yep two hours awesome thanks so
much
look I'm take care all right good show
today I really appreciate everybody
being on today what a great day what do
we get you on twitch did we break that
10,000 barrier I know we were uh we did
lievable just maybe like ten thousand
and 0.7 or something like that I mean
like they might ham yeah I couldn't keep
up with the comments it's going to crazy
no it's really really good like I'm
really I'm really really grateful to
twitch I saw something like number 28
like on the rankings so like we gotta
have a we have to we have to get the
team together and really go yeah I guess
about twitch you need to [ __ ] it we need
we need we need some emojis in my face
all right like there's a ton of cultural
things we need to do in there Tyler's
Tyler's gonna finally shine he's
obsessed so let's uh and then I'm gonna
get bugga to [ __ ] restream E and then
we'll really get into the very sick so
really appreciate it thank you so much
for everybody who joined in for a lot of
the new how many people are in here for
the first time comment
if it's your first time watching just
put in first just curious about that and
also when when we end up here nice a lot
of first let's go twitch coming in hard
I love it thank you guys so much thank
you so much
I'm just very humbled I will see you
tomorrow and most of all I know a ton of
you have have not have not signed up for
the podcast and looking at some data so
if you want to hear more positivity
consistently especially because I'm
worried that um post covet there will be
no tea with Gary Vee it is time for you
to subscribe to the podcast which is
absolutely the morning alternative here
it is I realized a lot of you that watch
tea with Gary Vee aren't designed up for
my podcast that makes me sad here's what
you're missing out on if you do not
follow the podcast you're missing out
listening to podcasts is this efficient
as [ __ ] when you're traveling to work
when you're on the [ __ ] treadmill
listen I get Rosie's dropping great
albums I understand forget your [ __ ]
knowledge up win for you don't consume
somebody else's music consume some [ __ ]
that will get yours
linked up sign up right now to the
[ __ ] podcast if you're not listening
[ __ ] up your summer right get on the
podcast
look at the profile get on it subscribe
leave a comment if you just did leave a
comment
[Music]